breaking news this morning Pope Francis
is taking major new steps to open up the
Roman Catholic Church's handling of
alleged sexual abuse by priests the
Vatican has announced that clergy abuse
cases will no longer be handled as
so-called Pontifical Secrets officials
say that will allow bishops to cooperate
more openly with police and alleged
victims
Seth Rhone is Seth Doane rather is in
Rome for us south good morning that
sounds like a move toward transparency
how big of a deal is it that's right
Tony it is a very big deal in fact
officials here at the Vatican are
calling a historic one of the most
significant results of that landmark sex
abuse summit that was held here you
might remember back in February now you
can think of the Pontifical Secret as
sort of confidentiality the
confidentiality some would say secrecy
that surrounds these proceedings where
they look into issues of clerical sex
abuse now many folks at the Vatican had
long argued that this secrecy this
Pontifical Secret was important to
protect the privacy of the victim but
sex abuse victims said it contributed to
the lack of transparency in these cases
and prevented civil law enforcement from
carrying out the investigations properly
and from accessing crucial documents
that was actually Pope Benedict who
instituted the Pontifical Secret in sex
abuse cases in 2001 remember back as
controversy exploded Pope Francis also
raised the age for the Vatican's
definition how they define child
pornography from 14 years old to 18
years old also today Pope Francis
accepted the resignation of an
archbishop the Holy See's ambassador to
France who was accused of sexual
molestation all of this is being
announced today
Jericka which happens to be Pope
Francis's 83rd birthday Wow a lot of
news coming out of Rome today Seth Doane
thank you